[Music]
foreign
[Music]
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
this was built on their shoulders
[Music]
let me get autograph no I ain't sounding
an autographs but you get off my car
you'll remember me huh
[Music]
Damien
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
glad to have you back out I know I've
been away a long time but kept myself in
shape I still got gas in the tank come
by the gym
thank you
[Music]
carers what happened with you too I
didn't tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though man I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
oh
nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I vouch for you you think
you mad trying to spending half your
life in the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Batman was like family
[Music]
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
[Music]
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is
[Music]